hello and welcome to this video playing
my hand draw wished don't know this is
right unfortunately you don't get much
of those obscure lines like the King
scam but I recently looked at the Kings
gambit quite a bit with black and it's
really not a good opening I really would
like to have it on the board sometimes
but yeah well people know that it's not
so great what what is he doing now oh
we're playing an Italian and I'm not up
to date really not I think nowadays what
I'm doing is not even the latest fashion
not even latest fashion I mean this is
wrong not still talking about fashion II
I mean this is not what is currently
believed to be best I think this time
I'd like to play this a little bit more
interestingly than usual it's really
hard him trying to play for long castles
for example it's really difficult him
hmm yeah I really regrets to go Queen to
e7 it wasn't a great idea Queen really
does not belong there
yeah this is actually good news I mean
it's nothing special really not but I
think taking with the Queen is better
this can be this can be slightly weak
long term but it's so it's so solid
young White's position
maybe can take on IG for maybe that was
not a good timing
or this one so similarly similar idea
even though here it is a little bit
maybe a little bit less of an issue
because after D for this night is
actually hanging so I might have night
therefore and a more favorable
circumstances hmm yeah and d5 before so
I should have played us
I should have timed this differently you
know Knight f4
there's no other discovery No
97 is not really doing much
okay yeah that's an interesting move I
did not think about this at all maybe
maybe I can play with this Knight takes
Knight takes h3 idea give this for
example takes Knight h3
yeah maybe I'm still okay and don't
quite believe it just like I have the
hunch that he's got something something
good I don't care this one oh I've got a
five-year there should be at least a
playable move it looks weird anyway
okay
now f5 is still hanging somewhat
somewhat hanging but
[Music]
[Music]
my Scott d5 hmm maybe I can take it it
looks really weird
and then you can take the take the thing
on a stream you can just take the light
nope now that I didn't like it that was
not good
the problem started really with d5 which
is just not a good time with another
well time move and I forgot that before
this idea it's often it's often a
problem really with those super slow
Italian positions where you kind of
think okay this is like you're so lame
nothing ever happens and then there
there are ideas ninety five is just not
a good idea I can prepare that and then
probably be okay now I actually felt 94
stronger you know but it's it's not it
is a problem anyway so Knight f4 is
better yeah I kind of have this hunch
that might there might be something
there f6 is really ugly means that I had
that I played and yeah this is in fact
quite good young Queen d5 this is double
attacking and this is still equal so
this is how I can keep it equal but now
I'm in trouble and have to have to do
all kinds of technical tactical trickery
and I have humble gym before f5 stood
okay here which I kind of suspected that
it could be still okay with Knight f4 I
just called back a g6 is bad
I thought he can just take but this is
not the case with g5 whose he is rocked
e5
I mean honestly this is the idea that
you know I have this no that's a bit
difficult and white has an advantage
with Queen d2 anyway yeah
strategically he's better he's got the
square here
and this is all not very nice yeah gee
I'm just toasted up to g6 yeah yeah I
think he played it okay right always
keeping something yeah well let's say it
make it difficult for me to equalize you
can equalize which is all nice and good
but you still have to find it okay
thanks for watching